voilà le nouveau test rsa de dell
franchement ce que j'aime beaucoup de
fourre tout
[Musique]
de retour à paris il fait super froid
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de vent je
vais vous parler aujourd'hui d'elle je
vous parlais je vous ramenez où ce jeu
vous ramenez les gaz pour vous parler de
ce que dell a présenté les grandes
innovations les grandes annonces
majeures mais avant sur 100 m en show
parce que si ça qui est grave
bon petit cendrier puis en faire un pour
les maliens que j'avais une coupe au
rire le stf quand même ces pays va
commencer a toujours le coût pourrait
s'élever jusqu'à pékin
ça c'est qu'ils appliquent à la bêta
c'est bien leur sms ça va eh bien oui
c'était fatigant ouest et bien tu as eu
ton c'est vrai c'est grave soit il est
là bas ça c'est quand même la grande
classe
félicitations ce tfc bravo bon alors
tout ça pour vous dire que je squatte
chez steve c'est bien dans son bureau
comme pascal relativement pratique et je
vous parle donc de dell je vous ramène
au csa vegas j'ai rencontré justin liles
lights pas que ces courges pas trop
votre nom qui est vice président comme
summer design chez dell on va aller voir
un peu ce qu'il a à nous raconter parce
que le plein de nouveautés d'être très
intéressant de 7
[Musique]
faux
auj
j'ai rendez vous avec dell dans 10
minutes seulement pas que ce soit en
retard donc mc casino dans venise viol
je cherche le meeting space celle à 2002
ça doit être par là bas c'est juste
énorme ici se retrouvent pour toutes les
machines à sous clandestines à 12h03 là
le nouveau j'étais stressée de dell
franchement ce que j'aime beaucoup et
surtout
très très bien les coups c'est la toute
petite caméra vous êtes des loyers avant
la khadra vous l'aviez en bas ici la
création trouveront et là franchement la
position evènement meilleur c'est juste
une bécane qui est vraiment super
optimisé alors j'ai racheté vous
souvenez c'est qu'apparaisse ps de dell
j'aime beaucoup ce ordinateurs tels a
vraiment fait un excellent travail sur
ses ordinateurs qui sont vraiment
parfaits pour bosser pour l'avoir à la
maison c'est pour moi la gamme parfaite
j'aime beaucoup en tout cas le bourg qui
a été fait là dessus le fait qu'ils
aient vraiment corriger ce point au
niveau de la caméra
c'est vraiment excellent parce que c'est
un peu ce qui gâcher la fête alors on
n'utilise pas très souvent sa caméra là
mais pour un usage professionnel pour la
visioconférence c'est franchement un
point d'amélioration qui est vraiment
significatif
[Musique]
new york émis 10 lignes ou
à
[Musique]
titre
non
ni d'auto à paris une heure et demie du
match je préfère d'élite et la vidéo je
mange pour quelques lustres à votre top
c'est pas très bon
franchement les solutions dell une fois
la solution que de nous a présenté au
csa
je trouve très intéressant permettez que
je veux quand je me vis des rouges les
solutions dell serré cette année j'ai
trouvé assez intéressante de le ccx pèse
13 s'offre un design améliorer et
corriger ça c'est vraiment très bon
point surtout l'alienware legends qui
vous vraiment une nouvelle voie cette
gamme alienware
c'est juste magnifique voir si
maintenant en face les consommateurs les
gamers seront réceptifs
oui ou non ça ça donne en tout cas je
trouve que ça va vraiment dans le bon
sens c'est vraiment intéressant
donc on va continuer à surveiller tout
ça et puis on testera un peu plus tard
ses produits dont vous aide à faire une
seule chose c'est à vous abonner depuis
deuxième chose pour marquer ce que vous
voulez en bas en commentaires questions
suggestions interrogations tout ça voilà
allez soyez sages
moi je leur ai couché ciao